(exotic music)
- So, I'm Indian, from Mumbai,
so that makes me a Hindu.
Everything that Indians do has a meaning,
or some culture towards it.
- My heritage is English/Irish/Scottish,
obviously, pale skin.
- My Mom was born in Taiwan,
my Dad was born in China,
and I was born in Detroit, Michigan.
(chuckles) So I'm very
ABC, American-born Chinese.
- Okay, oh, wow.
Oh, my God. (chuckles)
I love this headpiece.
I could get away with
doing the eyes everyday.
- Oh, my gosh, wow, uhh.
It's insane, I've never
looked this regal in my life.
It's a bit historical,
like the queen, darling. (chuckles)
- It's traditional,
but at the same time, there's
like, that element of,
there's like an edge to it.
It's so cool.
(laughing) Like, I love it!
I'm like, walking out just like this.
- It looks so authentic.
- It's like taking the
tradition to the present time.
- I feel pretty. (chuckles)
(exotic music)